quelques-uns qui voudront pousser plus
loin avec les élus du territoire avec
les représentants du monde agricole
aligné comme un seul homme les
représentants de la réunion sont
attentifs à la ministre de l'outre-mer
le diadème géré des financements
européens direction des dom on prend
presque beaucoup au pays
mais il ya également deux quoi
financement qui passe par l'audi à domme
et donc c'est un organisme payeur pour
tous les trois maires et qui et ça c'est
très important pour nous de maintenir un
organisme comme ça au sein de l'état
français parce que ça nous permet
effectivement de de mieux cibler les
problématiques que nous avons fait et
parmi le cortège olivier a tenu à être
présent il est producteur de bananes et
transformateurs as colimaçons saint leu
est quand même à positive dans la
réflexion je pense que ça va se faire
mais le problème c'est que ça va se
faire ça va se faire mais plus vite et
se sert le mieux quoi pour patton que
comme on dit qu à brimont salade
toujours commencer d'abord par quelques
douceurs avec la ministre attaque ainsi
son tour des stands de l'outre-mer et
rapidement nous représentons dirige les
débats urgents d'exploitation ce qui est
remarquable sont des gens qui produisent
transforme toute la plus value est
adapté ont entièrement à mal par la
crise
vanille de la réunion ça va s'arrêter
comme ça et annoncera vanille la réunion
mais la première vanille européenne une
occasion d'interroger les exposants sur
leurs messages à l'exécutif a tellement
de difficultés administratives dans les
dossiers lalonde de l'ami sera-t-il si
tout ça serait simplifié en un mois tout
est réglé pour que les projets aboutis
la défense n'aurait beaucoup plus de
développement agricole n'aurait beaucoup
plus de développement économique par
notre domaine à la réunion remporte un
gros souci demandeur je remets bien que
la ministre arena chinook ont pas des
choses on remet tout le travail c'est
parce qu'elle est la solution mince
aussi demandeur doit très bientôt
mais le géranium c'est un métier
difficile très difficile et
oui pour m'aider oui il faudrait que de
la réunion et internationalement fait
connaître le géranium rosa on aime
innover on aime créer
il faut qu'on arrive à mettre en avant
la réunion et qu'on arrive à reconnaître
son savoir faire et faire savoir
on a un savoir faire on a le café le
plus ancien du monde
on a des nouveautés comme le citron
caviar ou poire combavas retenez la
qualité et le goût à la réunion nous
avons envie de travailler nous avons
envie de développer mais avons pas
souvent dans le donne les moyens pour le
faire qu'en métropole à la france est
grande et il faut nous donner la
possibilité de se développer ici
[Musique]
entre temps le premier ministre est
arrivé
la dimension change compliqué d'être
contactez nous sommes déplacés jusqu'à
lui et on lui a rappelé combien combien
on compte sur notre état membre la
france pour défendre les intérêts de
notre pays la france dans la politique
agricole commune et surtout qui est un
réflexe régions ultrapériphériques de là
pour la réunion pour l'ensemble des
départements d'outre-mer
c'est essentiel dans les discussions
difficiles iksanov
au niveau l'euro l'idée c'est comment
ensemble ont construit le nouveau modèle
insulaire de nouveau modèle agricole
insulaire
comment on se prépare et on est même
dans l'excellence par rapport à la
métropole à l'hexagone sur un certain
nombre de références comme le zéro
carbone le zéro déchet le 01 30
chimiques
comment on montre y compris d'ailleurs
au monde qu'en france gall meilleur et
que cette france là se trouve dans les
territoires d'outre-mer retraite des
agriculteurs difficultés administratives
distribution équitable de la richesse
développement durable la tête plein de
sujets mais le ventre plein la mine east
side le salon sous le regard du monde
agricole réunionnais
[Musique]